this is a production
of Cornell University
it's March 11th 2014 and we have had a
very cold winter I'm at the Lansing
research farm we hit minus 10 here on
January 22nd and then had several other
instances where we went below zero so
Adam and I are out here cutting buds to
see what's alive and what's dead and so
I wanted to show you how this process
works and so what we do is we use a
razor blade and cut a way up buds and
look at what's alive inside and so we're
gonna zoom up on a bud here and you need
to remember that great buds are what we
call compound buds and so within each
bud that we cut there's actually primary
a secondary and a tertiary bud and I
found a great example here for what's
alive so what I've done is come in here
and that's what the bud looked like I
sliced it with the razor blade opened it
up and you can actually see the three
buds here this Center one is the primary
and there is the secondary and then
there's a little green dot over here and
that's the tertiary bud so this is great
we can look at the other side of the bud
here too and you can see those green
dots those are buds that are still alive
after this winter they all have the
potential to produce shoots so what will
happen is the primary will grow first
and as long as it grows well it's
unlikely the secondary or the tertiary
will ever grow if we move up the clone
here is another bud that I cut and in
this you can see that the center of that
is actually brown and so that's our
primary bud the primary bud is dead it's
been damaged by the cold but you can see
a little bit of green on either side of
that that's the secondary and the
tertiary and those are both alive
so this is what we do pre pruning if
we've had some cold damage is that we go
through we actually cut these buds with
a razor blade and look at what
proportion are alive and what proportion
are dead because that will tell us how
many buds we want to leave on the vine
because I'll know for example that to
balance this vine I want to have in this
example
thirdly live shoots but if I cut news
and I know that only about half of them
are alive that means I actually moved to
live 6 2 nodes rather than 30 to get my
30 shoots through the growing season so
in many years if we haven't had cold
damage we don't bother doing this but in
a year like this where we're seeing a
lot of damage in the Finger Lakes we go
through and cut some buds first so we
get a sample and figure out what's alive
and what's dead so we know how many more
buds we need to leave when we do our
pruning
so it's March 11th 2014 and I'm in the
Lansing vineyard we've had a very cold
winter and we've had some blood damage
that I wanted to show you so I've cut
some buds here and this is something
that we frequently do before pruning if
we've had cold events because we want to
see how many of our buds are alive and
how many of our buds are dead because
the number of buds were going to leave
on a vine well know the number we moved
to have a balanced vine for example it
might be 30 in this situation and so if
I know half the buds are dead I've got
to leave sixty buds so that I have third
issues so I've cut some buds here and I
wanted to show you you need to remember
that great buds are actually compound
buds and so within everybody there's
actually three smaller buds and this is
one where everything's dead but you can
see a bigger set of circles here that's
the primary bud this is the secondary
bud and this little one over here this
little wedge is called the tertiary bud
and on this one when we cut it open all
three are dead so the primary the
secondary and the tertiary are all brown
nothing is growing from that bud this
year the second one here it's a little
harder to see because the primary
secondary and tertiary are actually
alive here so this little middle green
point here this is our primary bud it's
alive and well if I had not cut it it
would grow into a chute there is our
secondary bud and there is our tertiary
over here which is alive too
so normally it's the primary that will
die first so it's easier to find buds
here where the primary is dead but the
secondary is alive and in that case this
secondary bud would actually grow and be
a chute in many cases it's not as
fruitful as a primary chute the fruit
will come out a couple of weeks later
and so it has less time to mature
through the growing season sometimes it
won't be a fruitful chute but at least
there'll be a chute there if the
secondary is alive and the primary is
not but in this case we're hoping to
find lots of buds like this because we
want to see an alive primary secondary
and tertiary bud this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at
Cornell edu